on your mark get set go
during the late 80s and early 90s there
was an epic kids game show called double
dare where kids got rewarded for being
messy today it's back on the air and all
along there's been one guy in charge
meet the man that got down and dirty for
seven years straight on the messiest
game show in America actually was eight
[Music]
my name is Marc summers and I was the
original host of the trivia game show
and very messy game show double dare
double dare is the show where we ask
questions if you don't know the answer
you can dare the other team they can
double dare your back if you don't
answer a question on our show you have
to take the physical challenge which
could include whipped cream slime or
some messy substance and that's how you
get points ultimately what you want to
do is go to the obstacle course run all
eight obstacles in 60 seconds or less
and win lots of money and prizes so the
first day you get on the set and I walk
out and there's an obstacle course which
I hadn't been told about and people are
dumping whipped cream and then this
green substance and I said what is that
and they said that's the slime back in
the day it was vanilla pudding apple
sauce and green food coloring now
Nickelodeon pay some company and
exorbitant amount of money to create the
slime it still has to be edible because
if it gets into kids mouth they have to
be able to digest it without any problem
back in the early days when we started
in 1986 I didn't know about the mess
I hadn't been diagnosed with something
called obsessive-compulsive disorder so
from 86 until about 94 when we did the
show there was this feeling of being
uncomfortable with times around all the
mess and slime and that's how I found
out what I had had a name
I'm gonna step back here just a little
bit we were referring to the slime as
gap what we find out after the fact was
that GAC was the slime term for heroine
Nickelodeon puts out a product called
GAC and after the fact didn't realize
that oops I guess we should have done
her homework one thing that people would
be surprised to know about the show is
we would test physical challenges and
bring in kids from different schools in
the evenings afterwards and if we
couldn't accomplish them three times it
never made air
we're not experimenting it's got to be
physically possible to accomplish it was
every kid's dream and almost every
adult's dream now to be on double dare
back in the day when we were doing the
show I was having the best time I live
I've been trying to give in to
Nickelodeon for the last ten years to
bring this show back and the answer was
always no no no no no I got an email
that said call us and they said we're
bringing it back but you won't be the
host you'll be the exec producer and I
said well who you gonna hire and they
said we found an influencer and I said I
have no idea what that means so they
told me about this young lady by the
name of Liza Koh she and I went online I
went oh my gosh she's like a 22 year old
Lucille Ball passing the baton was easy
simply because at 67 to be on
Nickelodeon and hosting a show would be
a bit ridiculous and I still have a huge
say so because as exec producer I'm able
to guide her and teach her and she takes
Direction extremely well so it's kind of
a marriage made in heaven
[Music]
people come out to me on a daily basis
and say oh my gosh
I grew up watching you and the fun part
here is when we're at double dare
shooting in Los Angeles come back to
Rose you're grownups and when I walk up
I always say this is my audience so they
applaud the weird thing is that these
people who are now in their 40s have
kids the same age they were when they
started to watch the show I'm honored
and flattered to have brought so many
good memories to a couple of generations
of people who look back on double dare
and when people come up and say nice
things I just say thank you for even
remembering
[Music]
you